and this is the key of unlocking the
success of our business and hopefully
the businesses that you either are
thinking about working for or a part of
and it's this it's so basic we all want
the same thing break break away the
differences between what I just
described language politics the way
people dress their history it doesn't
matter we all want the same thing we
want to be respected as employees we
want to be appreciated as customers we
want to feel dignified in the workplace
and who we are as people and we want to
go into a store and for that brief
moment of whether we're buying a cup of
coffee or whatever it might be we want
some value for our money and the human
condition of all of that between
business and the consumer and everything
everything everything else in between is
the human condition of the human spirit
if you can exceed the expectations of
your people if they feel they're working
in an enterprise or a company that
values them as human beings and not as
paychecks values them as human beings
and not a line-item on the balance sheet
and they in turn can take that feeling
of being respected and appreciated as an
employee and share that with someone
else a paying customer
whether it's in Kuwait or Dubai or the
opening of Starbucks France where people
said it wouldn't be possible it can work
and it is sustainable because the human
spirit has no language
and at a time in the world when there is
such cynicism and a fracturing of trust
if you reach out and appreciate and
respect another human being it comes
back to you